All right. We're going to talk about another clustering method. And just
to transition from the previous one, let's, let's take a look
at this data set here. We've got seven points. A, b,
c are all close together on the left. E, f, g are
all close together on the right. And d is equidistant from,
say c and e. In the k means clustering setting. If
we're looking for two clusters. What's going to happen to d? So,
one possibility is it ends up with the group on the left.
Another possibility is it ends up with
the group on the right. Another possibility is
that, depending on what happens from the
random starting state, it might end up on
the left or the right. And then
finally, it's shared between the two clusters. because
it doesn't really belong in either of them.
So it's sort of going to partly join both.
>> Oh, I see. So d is exactly in the middle between c and a. Okay.
>> That's what I intended to draw, yeah.
>> Okay, good. I think I can figure out the answer.